what is happiness now I'm a lawyer so I
have happy memories of spending a
semester in law school arguing about the
definition of a contract and if anything
happiness is even a more elusive concept
than that and so I got into this and I
quickly realized I'm not going to spend
my time trying to find a final
definition of happiness it turns out
there are more than 15 academic
definitions of happiness and you can
spend a lot of time arguing is it about
satisfaction is it about peace is it
about bliss is it momentary is it long
term and I really it didn't really
matter what I wanted to think about was
could I be happier today this week this
month how could I be happier whether my
happiness is not exactly the same thing
as your happiness it doesn't it doesn't
really matter and what I've also noticed
is the term happiness or happy is
intimidating to some people some people
deny that it's even possible to be happy
or to achieve happiness happiness sounds
like this magical destination that you
arrive at and then everything is sort of
solved or it's different so I think it's
easier to think about being happier even
people who deny the possibility of being
happy if you say do you think you could
be happier they'll say yeah I could be
happier so I think it's sometimes easier
to think about being happier for
whatever that means to you then worrying
about what is happiness and what would
life be if I finally achieve this
ultimate happiness
well to me I don't agree with that I
think that it's it's natural and I think
appropriate that when people have
reached a certain level of prosperity
and security they turn their attention
to higher things and we're very
fortunate that we're in a position to
worry about things like self realization
or sat job satisfaction and I don't
think that it's I think it's only right
that we should think about those kind of
issues I don't know what we would be
better spent thinking about